[Musique]
ces quelques pas sur scène entre la plus
petite des grandes dames du cinéma
français est l'une des plus grandes
stars du cinéma américains resteront
sans doute longtemps dans la mémoire du
cinéma français le week-end dernier en
recevant un oscar d'honneur pour
l'ensemble de sa carrière
agnès varda n'a pas seulement fait
danser angelina jolie elle a fait danser
tout hollywood
un week-end qui commence le vendredi
soir à les failles film festival le
festival de cinéma organisé par le
prestigieux american film institute
un festival qui adore agnès elle en a
même été la directrice artistique invité
en 2013 cette année n y était de nouveau
célébré à travers une petite fête donnée
en son honneur et surtout une master
class où elle était accompagnée de son
coréalisateur de visages village pierre
et du directeur d'unifrance serge
toubiana qui servait de modérateur un
entretien où on a enfin eu des
révélations sur la première rencontre
entre jr et agnes
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain plus de blagues ce samedi
soir c'est la fine fleur du cinéma
mondial qui est réunie sur hollywood
boulevard dans la salle de bal juste au
dessus du dolby theater où auront lieu
les oscars tous les ans jennifer
lawrence
helen mirren des six caccia staged
général une liste de stars interminable
venus célébrer les lauréats de cet oscar
d'honneur tout simplement le prix le
plus prestigieux que peut remettre le
cinéma américain
ici pas de compétition pas d'enjeu juste
l'envi de célébrer ce qu'hollywood
admire
parmi eux cette année le réalisateur
charles burnett alejandro inarritu le
chef opérateur owen rose man l'acteur
donald sutherland et bien sûr agnès
rencontre est justement sur ce tapis une
petite heure avant le début de la
cérémonie
reprenez une question très bête mais
pour santécois juste avant de recevoir
sonneurs bas juste on l'a donnée on me
l'a choisi donc je veux dire c'est c'est
une reconnaissance de mon vrai travail
j'ai tué ses deux maîtres de la lumière
sur des gens qui étaient dans la marge
ou pas de pouvoir ou révolté je n'ai pas
fait de comédie sur les milieux riches
et beauvoir en france c'est la même
chose
j'ai plutôt parler je sais pas des
glaneurs de délaisser des squatteurs
donc gg contenu est dans la ligne de ce
qui me semble important
j'ai jamais de cette publicité j'ai
jamais vendu de cosmétiques donc
s'inspire aussi certains jeunes à tenir
le coup et pour leurs projets donc je me
sens à l'aise
c'est un honneur mais je n'en fais pas
une patate comme on dit
elle n'en fait peut-être pas une patate
mais l'honneur est énorme
un honneur accordé par ses pairs qui
étaient venus nombreux de partout pour
lui témoigner une admiration sans bornes
agnès varda récompensé ce soir qu'est ce
qu'elle représente pour le cinéma
français
forcément cette série nicolas français
je suis vu dans le temps que qui
tiennent des grandes dames du cinéma
comme on devrait en savoir plus
abominables et madame bardasser pour moi
comme milestone c'est un exemple total
de cinéma nle mais des combats
et les grands patrons du cinéma français
avait aussi fait le voyage en plus de
serge toubiana il y avait aussi le boss
du festival de cannes thierry frémaux
venu juste 24 heures pour agnès et aussi
pour passer à vera spielberg et
frédérique bredin la présidente du cnc
et est elle aussi de la fête
impossible pour le cinéma français de ne
pas venir célébrer madame barda agnès
varda elle symbolise la nouvelle vague
symbolise l'avant garde avec symbolisme
des films d'auteur avec ce regard très
curieux cet oscar récompense une artiste
exceptionnelle mais avec une vision très
original du monde donc c'est vraiment un
coup de chapeau aux rendus au cinéma
français pour nous c'est merveilleux de
voir re qu'hollywood est tellement
attentif au cinéma français à 20 heures
la cérémonie commencée et les éloges
d'agnès continuer mais cette fois sur
scène
[Musique]
ils ne sortent knight alias compagnie
un peu plus de neuf heures du soir agnès
varda recevait enfin son oscar d'honneur
des mains d'andy rihs nahd joly
à homs lykke li shan and lights sourire
aux is beautiful to say to night une
fois the big band vers vicieuse full of
meaning and weight elle petit fils de
catherine louis de lights 9 à 12 à 12,9
il est financé dans son cinéma
[Applaudissements]
la fête a duré jusque tard dans la nuit
mais le lendemain agnès varda étaient au
rendez-vous de la petite partie
organisée par le consul de france à los
angeles pour célébrer l'événement
l'occasion parfaite pour revenir avec
elle sur cette belle soirée et sur ses
pas de danse improvisée avec angelina
c'était pas du tout prévu sap un génie
d'inquiéter la main tendue mais mr on a
fait un petit tour
ce n'était pas du tout prévu j'ai vécu
avec beaucoup de légèreté
le fait d'accepter aimé par hollywood
qui représente quelque chose de lourd
qui représente réussite le business le
bazar hollywoodien et j'étais la
pression d'être d'être une bulle là d'un
oiseau c'est bizarre de dire ça mais je
me sentais extrêmement légère et très
contente je me sentais mais de tous les
compliments que vous appelez sur scène
ou en or or celle hier y en a qui
veulent la plus touchée que c'est
toujours l'idée que j'inspire que
j'inspire aux femmes d'être indépendante
que j'inspire aux hommes de faire un
cinéma libre que j'inspire les jeunes
que ma détermination à faire un cinéma
qui ait du sens mais qu'ils soient pas
dans des cases
ça leur fait du bien il aime bien inside
vous avez certainement y redire
j'étais heureuse j'étais entouré de ma
famille de quelques français qui avait
pris la peine de faire le voyage
non j'ai été très impressionné de
l'extraordinaire gentillesse à mon égard
donc je n'ai pas pris comme de
l'admiration mais comme de l'affection
et c'est pas mal d'être aimé et ça tombe
bien madame varda parce que tous ceux
qui étaient là vendredi pour vous
écouter au festival de l'uefa samedi au
gouverneur the war pouvoir recevoir
votre oscar d'honneur ou dimanches
jusqu'au boire un verre avec vous tout
cela vous aime énormément et n'ont
qu'une envie continuer à vouloir croquer
la vie le cinéma et les oscars pendant
encore longtemps
[Musique]